склади ви повинні були zlodea ми з кандай
nicula лнр і кейджу боготу дні виходить
на демонстрацію бухаресті навпроти ден
куди засідай румунське уряд, що дозволяє
на сильний холод сюди приходять десятки
тисяч людей про та протестували проти
корумпованих політиків
люди вийшли на вулиці не позбавлять тут
рядовому кварталі протестують по всій
румунії
возити послуга 1000 скан дають люди
лиходіїв він і нас так і з іншим лиходієм
і робити пояснюючу винного в
азії нехай цеху підприємливого
Точніша 1000 адже його втратила а
ну прямо все своєю грою щипіт приймати
in виступів шляху домішки не тут move but
i побуду ванний новий склад для його
бізнесу злобний 100 предметів гігієни то
дезінфекції його клієнти
чи румунські corner у team теж швидкою
nicula і відразу милий
все босха барів далеко не заїдеш чи
читачі кориця біржа позаконкурс та
прописуються в румунії таким чином
червця можу початку відразу медок tatra
ми замінимо ось така задавайте йому
нічого не можемо з юдеї ти залишаєшся
сукні новим часто факін magic силі
каріння так і я бізнесмен перебивають
утримавши не гласності їх не корівнику
this але пов'язані з політиками про владу
за словами підприємства c
ідеально маріш для законних
маніпуляцій грушею мам даремно що й 1000
зустрінеться дали коріння
не закласти ймовірністю продукції а
вище вид розміру взяткою робити
ви знаєте ще vintage давав кабаре
по і моменту каньйон у момент калли
зі світ і все що без взятки поза як я сам
став частини на юті та корупційну машини
але ви могли ставало до пайових ніж та
прилади карету і відразу велику хвору
вся система
нехай чому с.м. приплив інтер мінералки
Адже стіна рентабельна тоді при будка
є бізнесу nicula я впала думі не можу
але здаватися seven обирається кожні
наріжте руму не перекинулася і бачила
трагічно заснув nikolay їжа на нас тут на
демонстрацію з зустрічається значить
складну акцію ти хто вийшов петром від і
уряд і вірити в них не мавпочка високих
зарплат та пенсій профільний до ряду
здається все-таки я книг вулик розколють
україну
бізнесмен перетнутих тонах вид по
знає через таких я клон і румунія
можна вилетить із європейського союзу
майдану я кому чого шураві збуваються
анти-а рядами демонстрації називається
майдан победи
Микола перука він вона ще вся назва
символічно у барбі проти корупції